porque ha estado marcado el mandato de
Alejandro yamate Y por qué será
recordado
viene de la élite política muy
tradicional en en Guatemala y eso alguna
forma afecta su imagen y su popularidad
frente a la población de hecho alguna
forma él está muy ligado con lo que se
conoce mucho con los grupos
ilegales y que están asociados a ciertos
capitales económicos que son muy fuertes
en el país y alguna forma su presencia
en el gobierno de alguna forma
favorecido mucho más esos intereses que
a los de la población eso se ve mucho
más reflejado en temas de corrupción de
sobre todo algo muy importante que sea
la nota Y es que en el presupuesto
nacional por ejemplo un gran segmento de
ese presupuesto fue a las
administraciones locales esas
administraciones locales pues obviamente
pues de alguna forma dependen del
ejecutivo para generar una serie de
programas Pero eso con una serie de
condicionamientos muy clientelares que
al final de cuentas lo que permiten es
mayor corrupción y mayor impunidad y
sobre todo tener también en cuenta que
Guatemala tiene una historia muy
reciente de lucha contra la corrupción y
contra la impunidad con la sisic y
obviamente este presidente pues
obviamente ha sido muy favorable a los
intereses que se oponen a esa cicic
entonces obviamente lo que tenemos es
que yamatei es una continuidad un poco
más de esas élites que desde 2015 han de
alguna forma han generado una serie de
contrapeso de resistencia a esas
comisiones a esos intentos de los
guatemaltecos por acá la corrupción y la
impunidad en su país